Speaker 1: Well, it's another day in the United
States and another several mass shootings.
Remember, even when they don't make the news,
there are typically a number of mass shootings
every day in the United States. Yesterday,
there was one that did make national news.
It took place at the Covenant School, which
is a Christian private school in Nashville,
Tennessee. As of right now, we believe six
people were killed as well as the shooter,
three children. Three staff members were among the
dead. The shooter has been identified as a 28 year
old former student killed by responding police
officers. And very quickly, the sum total of the
narrative from the American right wing has become
that the shooter was trans and thus everything
from drag shows to gender affirming care are to
blame. Oh, and psychiatric medications as well
are to blame for what took place. The shooter had
no criminal record and had attended this school
at an early age, according to the Tennessean. The
shooter was a trans man who used male pronouns.
And immediately this is the sort of reaction that
we get from anti-trans activist Matt Walsh. Always
remember what happened at the Covenant School.
Remember what happened to those innocent victims,
to those children. We are facing a truly
demonic evil. Never forget that. Radical
Republican Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
GREENE says, quote, How much hormones like
testosterone and medications for mental mental
illness was the transgender Nashville school
shooter taking? Everyone can stop blaming guns.
Now, Candace Owens jumping into the mix saying,
when you play Frankenstein with people's body
parts, this is code for gender affirming care
that sometimes includes surgery. When you play
Frankenstein with people's body parts, you can't
be surprised when they behave like monsters. A
person willing to execute violence upon his or her
own body will not hesitate to impart violence onto
someone else's linking. I guess gender dysphoria
to being violent against other people,
which doesn't make any sense and has never
been demonstrated empirically. Dan Bongino says,
quote, Because it has rarely failed me, I'm going
to wait until I have the details of the Nashville
attack before offering detailed comments. However,
after spending the past 2 hours reading the
absolutely grotesque comments by leftists about
this incident and the attack on Rand Paul's
staffer, a sane person can only conclude that
we're dealing with demons on the left. If you're
sane, says Dan, you would blame demons. There's
no other explanation for their evil. None. That's
a very, very interesting take. The now infamous
cat turd right wing account, which has gotten
the publicity of Donald Trump reposting their
content cat turd posts. They've been grooming
your children and now they're shooting your
children. Seriously, when are you going to stop
being afraid and start speaking out against evil?
At what point do you stop selling your soul to
cave to this woke mob again? Groomers to blame.
Benny Johnson from the right wing organization TP
USA Turning Point, USA tweeting. Three weeks ago,
Tennessee banned child gender mutilation. Today,
a transgender committed premeditated mass murder,
hate crime against Christians, killing six,
including three little children. This was an
act of demonic vengeance by a movement of
mentally ill domestic terrorists. Enough.
And then Laverne Spicer tweeting, The
anti-Christian rhetoric in our nation has
now resulted in a school shooting in Nashville,
Tennessee. So a couple of different things here.
First and foremost, there is no evidence
whatsoever that drag shows gender affirming
care. Demons or any of it are responsible for this
particular shooting. Furthermore, it is abundantly
clear that we aren't going to prevent shootings
with things like the Stop woke Act of Florida or
banning drag shows or banning the amorphous CRT,
which they seem unable to explain even what it is,
or whether it's even being taught in classes
or any of it. We do have a whole bunch of
different ideas with regard to gun safety,
none of which the right wants to implement,
which would certainly help reduce the number of
these incidents. No one. As I've said before, no
one policy would prevent every shooting. And I've
talked about before. And the gun show loophole,
universal background checks, mandatory waiting
periods, no high capacity weapons under age 25,
mandatory gun insurance, required community
support letters. If you're buying a gun and
you're under 25, ban some weapons, periodic mental
health evaluations, extensive licensing process,
gun buyback program, all. But, David, the gun
buyback program wouldn't have prevented that
shooting or banning some weapons, wouldn't have
prevented this shooting. That's right. But all
of these things would prevent some shootings. One
other note about this. I posted a tweet yesterday
sort of calling out the fact that despite
continuing to ask for thoughts and prayers
and saying that part of the problem we have is God
has been taken out of school, I pointed out this
shooting happened at a Christian school. This was
either deliberately or accidentally misinterpreted
by some as me blaming the kids who were shot. And
of course, I would never do that. Unfortunately,
I took that tweet down because of the number
of threats that came in, not only against me,
but against members of my family, people finding
my family's contact information and going after
them. So I did delete the tweet. The point I was
making, of course, was that Republicans who offer
nothing other than prayers are unwilling
to implement any of the policies I just
mentioned and continue saying the problem isn't
guns. Clearly, this was not an issue of that,
given that it was a Christian school. That is
what I meant. Unfortunately, the threats are
raining down and I did delete that tweet for
those who are asking. We will continue talking
about this. Let's briefly take a detour into a
mom who was able to get in on a Fox News segment
to say, when are we going to actually
do something about the gun safety issue?